i want to make an important note before
the video starts that if you haven't
read the attack on titan manga don't
know how it ends or don't want to know
how it ends yet
this video does contain heavy spoilers
for the final chapter
it might not be your cup of tea i know
that i'm normally anime only friendly
but i felt obligated as a primarily
attack on titanfocus channel to make a
video about the ending now that it's
finally here and making big news
plus i uh i just wanted to talk about it
so
the spoiler warning behind me here we go
after 11 and a half long years chapter
139 has brought a close to the
monumental series of attack on titan
the series who tops my anime list's most
popular manga
whose anime adaptation became the number
one most viewed television series in all
of america during season four
its impact will probably never be lived
down and there were hundreds of
thousands
if not millions of people waiting on how
it would close in chapter 139
so how was it how did we all react
personally i loved it of course that's
just my opinion if you go to the
comments to blast me at least do it
respectfully
but also hear me out because i know a
lot of people were left with a couple
if not many complaints and i'm not
trying to fight anyone or start any beef
just give my reasoning on why i enjoyed
it and hopefully you can see
the brighter side of isaiah's writing or
maybe see why it's not as extremely bad
as you may think if you think that
one of the biggest problems people had
with the chapter that i saw on twitter
and stuff was how it basically reduced
aaron from this developed
serious anti-hero type character to a
jealous lovesick brat
which yeah you can see it in that way
but i don't think this was as
serious of a hit to his character as
people really think it is
ever since aaron saw the future when he
kissed to story his hand he has been
completely different a man on a mission
extremely serious and devoted absolutely
to the future he thought was best for
the world
but it was also so sudden a shift in his
character that anyone that i think
felt remotely attached to aaron before
that happened saw a huge
change in their favorite character that
went largely unexplained for a long
period of time in the manga
and i personally thought that this
dehumanized him
i think that yeah seeing the future
understandably took a toll on his mental
state and that of course he would change
so what i'd love to see in chapter 139
is that it showed that aaron is still
behind all that before that happened is
still just a teenager
he's really just some kid who was
burdened with being one of
actually many martyrs for the future he
saw
he did feel regretful towards armin he
does still love mikasa he cares about
each and every one of his friends enough
to visit them through the path
individually and tell them about his
plan
it restored that sympathetic human side
to his character that we haven't seen in
so
long and that's how i saw it granted the
only cheesy part and panel that i really
didn't like about this chapter because i
didn't love everything
was the part where he complains that
mikasa should only love him
i thought it was kind of forced and the
delivery of it really did make it feel
like
less making him human and showing that
he's still a kid to making him into a
brat
so in this sense i can definitely see
where people are coming from but
other than that i thought it did justice
pretty well to his character
it brought back aside to his character
we haven't seen in super long and i
thought that i mean i was really happy
to see it
there's also the fact that aaron
basically just pulled a lelouch which is
making himself the villain for the rest
of the world so both sides were formerly
enemies would connect and become allies
over the
common enemy they shared which i mean if
you're complaining about that now
this was literally so obvious that it
was going to happen for the past like 20
chapters
there was literally a 100 chance aaron
had some ulterior motive behind the
rumbling but also
it was surprisingly different in my eyes
from the ending of code geass
in a fashion that i found very much
befitting of attack on titan
look that was a lot of words let me
explain further when code kiosk finished
it was basically assumed that
everyone was just happy that dictator
zero was gone and lived out their lives
in harmony together
but that's not what happened in attack
on titan aaron had to kill 80 percent of
humanity
and that literally just staved off the
fighting the jageris
still built an army afterwards and at
the end after everything's over it's
still up to the survey corps who have
seen both sides to try and make peace
whether that's even possible
which is exactly what attack on titan
has always been about
that humanity will always be fighting if
you leave even 20 percent of them like
aaron did then they will keep fighting
it's the cycle of hatred and so now he
must entrust
building that peace to armin and the
survey corps because more needs to be
done
and i think that cruel fate that there
is so much more peace to be made despite
everything aaron has done and sacrificed
for this cause
is exactly the kind of ending befitting
of attack on titan
i think that the series put enough of a
twist on pulling a lelouch in a way that
is very tragic and
almost disappointing that not everything
was fixed by what erin did
it's exactly what attack on titan would
do it's exactly what isayama would do
and that's what i love about it
and here i'll stop addressing complaints
for a little bit and just straight up
talk about what i loved
first levi's ending this is one of the
few things i found very few if any
complaints about
because it was beautiful we've already
seen the souls of former scouts in this
way before
but for some reason seeing levi at you
know his physically worst
after everything finished with a single
tear going down his face doing the
salute
was just so sad to see and so precious
he's finally at peace he no longer has
to keep fighting
to keep living up to the expectations of
the souls burdened on his shoulders
if anything actually he has to now live
up to their hopes of peace of living his
life with no more fighting
i think that's what anyone would have
wished upon levi
[Music]
likewise i think the feelings after
titans were removed from the planet was
amazing reiner's mom telling him that
she just needed him
that being an honorary marlian or
fighting for the country meant nothing
compared to that was
awesome especially for reiner one of the
characters most mentally and emotionally
burdened with betrayal and the
consequences of being a titan to see him
relieved of that duty
finally was great for his character
connie knowing that his mother is
finally saved a small but constant plot
point
all of it was just so awesome in my
opinion i also thought it was really
cool how aaron was the one who sent dina
fritz to eat his mom and spare bird
holds
not like really cool that like oh aaron
killed his own mom but more cool
story-wise
it was just another testament to how
mentally burdened he was
knowing that he forced his own father to
eat the royal family and dina to eat his
own mother
and betray his friends it just makes his
story so much sadder and more tragic
when realizing what he had to do
all on his own i also thought it was
perfectly fitting that the way that the
conflict resolved on the mainland
between them was
not because it was all over that the
fighting was finished
but that they talked that armin came to
discuss it with them and that everyone
really had to think it over that
violence wasn't even the solution
which again fits in exactly with the
themes of attack on titan and makes
armin's character
all the more important we've known that
from the start or should've
that armin was chosen for a reason that
dealing with issues in a way separate
from violence
is the solution is the only one that
really works without creating
even more violence
and now back to some complaints people
were pretty unhappy i think that
historia didn't even get aaron's kid
that she really did just have some
random farmer's baby
and that almost any character
development was kind of thrown out the
window
which okay yeah it's kind of upsetting i
mean it was just a red herring
which is a clue in literature that's
meant to be distracting and purposefully
mislead the viewer or reader
and i mean i can't really go much into
depth about this but yeah i see why
throwing out her character is kind of
saddening but
i mean she also just looks happy to be
herself
a mother and a wife and a queen
something that she could never
do as a kid as she hid her identity as
she was forced to be someone by her
father
it's very similar to levi's story in my
opinion
you know just food for thought and the
whole thing with yamir waiting for
mikasa
it had me pretty confused i'm not gonna
lie i don't know everything
but i guess if i had to put it into
words it was that mikasa could do what
ymir couldn't
despite the love she had for aaron she
had the resolve to kill him for the sake
of ending the violence
ymir loved carl fritz and couldn't stop
him even though she knew
he was cruel it's just poetic i guess
this was probably one of the bigger plot
twists about chapter 139 the importance
of mikasa
and i honestly think it could have gone
without this
you know without her being the destined
one for ymir and aaron's rant about
wanting to be with her still
and i think she still would have felt
super important even if these parts were
gone
it became kind of cheesy towards the end
how much they were buttering her up but
you know you can't be perfect and i
think that's what a lot of people who
are complaining
can't realize or just refuse to
there are millions of attack on titan
fans who are waiting on this chapter
so from the get-go there was no way that
everyone would be happy with the ending
that's always how series work comparing
it to game of thrones feels
pretty stupid to me and kind of
exaggerated i don't think it was nearly
that bad as someone who's watched that
series as well
i think almost every character except
maybe aaron
but even i think he was justified in
that last part
got a pretty solid ending and it fits
with the tones of attack on titan
which i think is honestly the most
important that making an ending isn't
just for the sake of making everyone
happy but for fitting in with what the
story has set out
and also blaming isayama for this is
just sad
it's like where aot fans raged at mappa
for not animating it properly
even though it's literally top 5 on my
anime list now like
some people just can't be happy with
something
seeing aaron be human again showing his
passionate side towards his friends
after dealing with the pain and mental
strain of seeing past
future and present all at the same time
and trying to control it
while also giving justice to armin and
mikasa and levi and proper ends for many
of our characters like
come on give isaam some props
what'd you guys think try not to start a
fight in the comments let's let's be
gentlemen
but i don't know i was happy maybe i'm
not such a die-hard fan or maybe i'm
just not as picky as other people
or maybe i saw what esan was really
trying to do but
that feels kind of extra i don't think
i'm that special
anyway this has been the anime culture
corner i hope you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
[Music]
analyses
you